genau diese wo das wo das Knie schlecht
gemacht wird einfach ausgedrückt wo wir
das belegen können da sind keine
Kniespezialisten die Angriffe werden
nicht oft genug gemacht es gibt viele
Komplikationen das werden wir öffentlich
machen der springende Punkt ist wenn ich
in all den Kliniken die Dinge nicht mehr
bezahlen die die Kliniken nicht gut
können dann gehen diese Patienten für
diese Eingriffe in Klinken wo das gut
ist dann kann dort auch besser bezahlt
werden weil ich war ja sehr viel Geld
und somit die anderen gehen pleite das
sollten wir jetzt auch dazu sagen wenn
die wenn ich jetzt in vielen Bereichen
Probleme habe dann wird das Haus sich
nicht halten können
[Musik]